hey townies welcome to another episode
of dumb people Town population
[Music]
Scoville ah folks we're here we're doing
it again that's right
Rory scoble is with us
um
no Dan I'm not sure if you guys know Dan
Daniel yeah Dan does another podcast
called pen pals with someone and I can't
remember it's cheating on our podcast
hi I'm the homewrecker so it's nice to
have the mistress here he's at our
dinner table two other podcasts that
they do here's the good news is that uh
the chemistry between Dan and Rory on
pen pals is magical if you're not
supporting it subscribe it's a fun show
do what's your problem here's the other
thing is that since Rory's been on a
show last time the world has gotten
dumber and as we do on this show we get
stories sent by our great fans is that a
scotch and soda jacket of course you are
on brand can I get you
I don't know if I do enough where it
would where it would uh make sense for
them to throw clothes at me like enough
appearances I mean for them to do I
would so you're on this show right now
and we're gonna try and fight dumb with
funny that's what we do that's literally
if I say someone's like what do you guys
doing on the show we fight dumb with
funny or at least try it up try to
understand why what's going on I have
the first story let's get into it you
I'm so excited you ready thank you I
like his shoes too and I was listening
these are very Dan Van perky no one said
anything about my sweater yet not one
thing that it was a birthday present
you're wearing a similar ready this one
was sent in by Jake Rooney at Jake grown
he loved Jake Rooney sends in a lot of
great ones gets there first okay here we
go Bedford man
stole truck
found in trailer according to police
okay so there was a truck in a trailer a
little bit of a Russian doll situation
this is they they screwed this the the
the headline on this thing they didn't
write it correctly and as you find out
in the story it's two crimes that have
been committed and he's been a part of
both so it is and it's just wonderful
and there's a moment in there where
you're like okay this is why it's dumb
people is Natasha Leone did she switch
Souls with an old lady no Natasha Leone
is married to Moshe Kasha she's the one
who did this okay that's Natasha Bedford
Pennsylvania
WT AJ a Bedford man is facing charges
after he was accused of stealing a
stranger's truck before taking it to the
trailer he claimed he was born in
accordance State Police
you guys know where were you born where
were we born you were born yeah
St Louis Missouri right same same as
them
uh Jewish hospital in Greenville South
Carolina that's not true
they just call it the hospital yeah I
mean I was born but like how many people
are like running around being like I was
bored this is where I was born here I
mean clearly if you're stealing a truck
to get back to the trailer you're
claiming you were born in you were not
born in that trailer I don't know I have
so many questions I'll let you finish
Kenneth Welch Jr it's a great name yeah
is should we get his age right now how
old do you think he is let's find out
what he did let's find out what he did
as the last name already sounds like a
writer that's just trying a little too
hard where as soon as you read it you go
no one that's Owen's name
Welch on the deal was he watched on the
deal did you Welch on the beaches
grapefruit that's right grape juice
grape juice I've never had Welch's
grapefruit ever Welch's grapefruit juice
I bet you they do it why'd they stop at
grapes seriously orange I did just show
my son last night Gary Goldman's grapes
versus grapefruits a great job like bit
it's unbelievable unbelievable well so
Welch Jr is facing uh numerous charges
and you know it's going to hurt his dad
his dad who clearly
your Kenneth Welch senior Kenneth Welch
one kw1
you were not born in a trailer so you
could steal a truck to get back to the
place where you were born I'd raised you
differently it's facing numerous charges
related to both a stone truck the
reporter Berkeley uh called into uh PSP
just minutes apart state police were
called to a home on Sunnyside Road I'm
having a hard time I don't my my audible
learning is not great he is facing
numerous charges related to both the
stolen truck I understand
burglary he'd be a need at this trailer
oh where he was born right state police
were called to a home on Sunnyside Road
in Bedford September 29th at what time
were they called to the home it's
definitely early morning yeah it's like
early early morning two three I'm gonna
go three a.m Jay what do you think I'm
gonna say 11 A.M for some reason I my
first thought was 304 am but I'm not
gonna do but it's gonna end up being so
reasonable let's make 1 p.m everyone was
done with lunch in the morning right he
said 11AM that's pretty reasonable so 11
A.M 3 A.M and what do you say to him 304
I'm gonna go 1am 1am get your answers in
townie townies because state police were
called to the home on Sunnyside Road in
Bedford at 8 A.M 8 A.M he's talking in
for work so wait by the way that could
have been stolen 11 A.M Eastern no it's
already on the east coast today 11 A.M
London time all right so yeah this
answer everyone's answer should work
although it is 5 a.m Pacific so we're as
close he's flying on a transcontinental
flight
Daniel right it is 1am Hawaii got up at
8 A.M he so the truck could have been
stolen at three Rory could be right or
you could be right at once sure this guy
got up at 8am and realized his truck was
gone so he called the police that's what
I meanwhile two different state troopers
out of Bedford were called to a trailer
on Elk Road you know the Elk Road
that's where you're born the Elk Grove
trailers that's where you want to be
born that's the good trailers yeah when
you look back I wish I was born there
now I did I know he didn't take a stolen
truck uh out to a burglary because that
would be stupid right if you took a
stolen truck and then you started
burgundy he had no other way to get
there do you want to take your truck yes
that's a great idea a witness told
police he saw an unknown male later
identified as well to drive up in a
truck and try and get into the trip
trucks like what and then try and get
into the trailer I would think that no
trailer is locked hold on so this guy's
trying to get into a trailer just
because he was born there yeah but like
people live people are like living their
lives he's hammered I didn't know that
what did he need who says you can't go
home again can we give the police some
credit here because there's a stolen
truck elsewhere and they're like we
gotta find this truck and then someone's
like I saw someone drive drive up in a
truck and try and get in a trailer and
somewhere finally like you know how like
in the 1970s no police stations were
ever working with each other and they
were networking the band at work they
would never connect the dots ever
I didn't know trailers could be passed
to different families I thought that
like one family lives in a trailer until
they die and then it gets burned down or
a tornado a tornado carries it away yeah
but it's also okay if you are returning
to the place of your birth right you're
in some sort of Highlander scenario
that's what I wonder like maybe he his
story maybe he needed to there was like
a curse yeah like it just sounds like
it's kind of fun trying to climb back
into my mama yeah like I just Grandpa's
goblet I just see him peeling out on the
truck to get to the trans
cause I gotta get back to where I was
born yeah and I feel in my mind too he
has one sycophant like there's someone
in his life who's on for his journey
like believes him and is like cheering
him on the whole way I love it and he
literally he bursts in the trailer he
goes don't kill the cops I literally
have to be here for a reason because
there's a spell and it'll save my whole
family in the whole world
like Andy's here now my arm is being
erased my arm's being erased in this
photo that's Rory's favorite move of all
time also you're on to something here
because if you are ever saying to
anybody you're not gonna believe this
things are wildly gone wrong right yeah
even if what you're saying is true
it's an uphill let me try to get ahead
of your fear of you you're not going
straight let me get ahead of why you're
concerned rain is off of the track let
me stop you before you hit the last one
in the night that's what I was gonna say
if you're living in a trailer where
people are coming back to where they
were born you
I was born here and I go
I don't know why
there's Rory wants to know this story I
might I actually think I'm on team Welch
okay there you go me too brother
30 minutes ago what like two people this
is a Jewish trailer hospital that's
where they were born and they fall in
love
all right this is the movie two people
break into the same trailer 30 minutes
apart because that's where they were
born and we call it mobile home is where
the heart is
what if what if they rebooted big and
the kid turned into Tom Hanks in a man
called Otto yeah like turned into just a
grumpy old hungry right winger or that
okay fine uh Sunny so it was discovered
that the truck was once reported stolen
from Sunnyside Road when police entered
the residence they found Welch and this
is where I was like this is a dumb
people down story they found Welch
laying in a closet laying in a closet in
the closet according to the criminal
complaint probably the closet he was
born in right just laying there I mean I
know a trailer is small but it has a bed
right a trailer yes
why would some trailers are very nice
just laying there
on Elk Road I know that's the one you
want did he get tired mid burgle is my
question no he's hiding because he heard
the cops coming up wait so he's laying
in a closet that is an R Kelly album
but by this point it's probably around 9
A.M right right because the 8 A.M the
truck reported so they get there at like
nine exactly he's coming down I mean or
does he have ADHD so he's like what did
I come in here to do again yeah where am
I going and the cops are like literally
like already high-fiving going this is
the fastest we've ever solved anything
two crimes two in one one hour two birds
one here's your truck this guy he's
making a lot of fun for a guy who's on
some sort of George Bailey situation
more before breakfast than you do
anything wait dan is trying to link this
too I'm just saying we're really hard on
a guy who's in some sort of George
Bailey situation that's what I mean we
need to know this guy's starting
I get out of here bird I'll hit you
again Pirates when interviewed Welch was
asked how he got into the trailer he
reportedly supplies to police he was
born there spiritually maybe physically
and then again did he go back to the
closet going back to the closet is like
another lion which in the wardrobe
scenario he also told the police he also
told police that the stolen truck was
there when he arrived and he was never
inside of it that thing hey that this
person saw me get out of I don't know
where I got here yeah there's going to
be a lawyer who's very happy he's not I
believe him so now I love that he's got
a plan that he's like
that was there man he's not trying to
say that he came back to the place he
was born he's they come in and they're
like that's right I'm with you I was
born here this is my plate like that he
was trying to say I was born right now I
was born in this no I'm just born how
could I have committed a crime I'm just
born in this closet
so you're saying so you guys believe in
original sin that's what we're all
getting here right here that you're born
what happened as soon as Conway put the
words our alternative truths out there
now we can't argue with him can I cannot
I didn't land on this
oh I know wait who landed where and why
they don't say nothing about the truck
whatsoever he's like I came here on foot
not on that stolen truck out there we
didn't say anything about it
come on well you know you can't break in
here we didn't ask you if you did
police reported that he was barefoot
when they found him and sandals the same
size as Welch's feet were found stuck in
the truck that's where you [__] up man
you can't leave the sandal in the truck
a lot of people have similar Size Feet
you know by the way this is how Jesus
got busted right was that the OJ trial
uh
yes that's it police noted that uh in
the affidavit that Welch refused to
answer any other questions I love that
he was like I'll give you the fact that
I was born here and the fact that I
don't know about that stolen truck we
never said it was stolen right and the
fact that my sandals are in that truck
but I'm not saying anything else I will
not answer this is not this is not his
first uh robbering Rover sir why are you
wearing sandals to a burglary that also
feels way too casual that's I mean
that's what I feel like is in his face
and also why would I wear sandals to a
burger
that wouldn't why wouldn't you wear them
into the trailer you need to find the
guy who stole my sandals and put them in
the truck that's who we need to be
looking for I'll help you the guy who
reported this truck stolen why did he
eventually steal my sandals with the
truck to frame me and then drive the
truck here to where I was born also and
then left weakest argument and he put
his two minutes like this I'm just
saying you got to ask yourself yeah I
know you got to ask yourself this is
right there
Bedford County prison on Bedford Falls
right there yeah on theft burglary and
trespassing as well as lesser related
charges bail was set at how much for the
truck theft and how much for the
burglary we'll do it separately
combine them
we'll combine them both Total bail for
this this is where we find out Randy
can't do math
breaking and entering truck theft and
breaking and entering how much total
combined I have no I have no idea about
Bailey said it based on have they
arrested you but it's so arbitrary it
can't be like crazy what they think you
can pay so if like I do not like if Elon
Musk gets like does something weird
Millions well that's billions like a
billion dollars or whatever it is B
um
I'm gonna go
25 000. what do you think god that's way
higher than I was gonna okay then I was
gonna say like somewhere between five
and ten but now I feel like a no I'm
just gonna do whatever you want I feel
like a loser you might be right you are
but just uh you are just guess I mean
you're totally wrong but you might be 2
500 bucks 2500 oh my God no I feel so
much lowballed yeah okay so get your
answers in town okay because his bail
for stealing the truck yeah and leaving
your sandals in a stolen truck because
that's an offense too sure criminal
Footwear yeah
seventy five thousand dollars oh and it
breaks down 25k for the truck 50 for
breaking entering oh well he well he
can't pay that no he won't he's gonna
leave each other they're going to ring
you up yeah how old is a nightmare how
old is the last one will ask how old is
uh Mr Welch see this is why I like that
we did at the end because I really know
this guy 27 I like it quick answer right
away what do you think 30
six years old Jay 49. get your answers
in counties and this is the last we'll
we'll get take a break right here we'll
come back and find out what Rory's doing
what Dan's doing what we've got going on
it's done people time I hope you're
enjoying watching this on the YouTube
channel on all things come as YouTube if
you listen to and you're like hey I want
to see this thing happen because great
things happen watch it all right
Mr Welch Jr yeah the pride of his
father's namesake yes is
31 years old
you did it Rory all right let's take a
break when we come back we'll find out
what everybody's doing it's dumb people
town with Rory Scoville it's a dumb
people Pals we'll be right back
stick around
welcome back to double palsy
article
John pen pal town is pretty good too
uh we'll get into pen pals and all that
stuff uh let's give you I'm not sure
when this is dropping so if it's a
couple weeks if it's I've got a tour
he's got a tour to promote I got stuff
but if it's after if it's before San
Francisco on February 5th uh Sunday
night Sunday night at Cobbs Comedy Club
live dumb people town it's going to be
epic if if you're a dumb people Don fan
and you live in the Bay Area and you're
not at the show you have to look at your
life and understand and try to
understand what you're trying to do uh
we want you there for that uh Randy and
I will be the days before that in San
Diego at the American Comedy Company I
think this might drop on the 7th of
February okay so if it's just after
thank you for coming uh Ren and I are
going to be at a giant Casino gig and
that's right in outside of Cincinnati
Lawrenceburg Event Center on October 4th
and that's gonna be a really fun in
October uh no not March March 4th I
wasn't making fun I generally thought
October
March 4th and I was like good Lord you
really know you're really pushing yeah
we know what's happening and then and we
will be able to tell you it'll be a moon
tower so we're just uh putting together
the uh finishing touches on our on our
schedule of Performing and whatnot and
uh Daniel what do we have going on for
you every single week you can come to
the lyric Comedy Hour it's Wednesdays at
7 30. uh Irene two and myself host that
show Irene will be there you got to get
you guys I told you at the other day and
you didn't answer me I said to both you
guys hey let me know when you want to I
would love to come and do it um it's a
great lineup of shows Rory did the very
first one was the very first set on the
very first maybe the best of it that's
what I love about you Roy you are there
for your people you show up no he said I
had to oh I made him sorry I don't want
to do it no you said there is no way in
hell I'm going to do it anymore
he's a bigger guy than all of us
besides pen pals which is their amazing
podcast and if you haven't heard it
listen to our episode first and then the
opportunity for you to go over and
subscribe to that podcast as well and
you should do it check it out it's a
good time and even if you just come for
a short period of time and then you go
onto other podcasts yeah now
relationships work we don't care
um I have a Monday night show at a
legion theater if you're in Los Angeles
and you're in the area go follow me on
Instagram uh Rory Scoville and uh all
that information what is that is that
just you or is it it's called The
whatever show so it's it there's
literally every show is kind of
different I might improvise now I might
do my hour I might just host and bring a
bunch of comics out I might have like
two bands we will do it something
different all right
we did a tune a two-hander one night
that's right that's fun fun uh come and
watch physical on Apple TV plus uh go
see babylon's probably streaming anytime
now it's not already and I am doing a
tour that starts in April going to many
dates uh Royce google.com we'll have all
that but also Instagram look at a poster
that I've posted go see him please he is
so funny do it let's jump into another
story let's do it are you ready yeah
here we go
um Dear dumb people town uh it says wife
this is the headline wife buys sex doll
to satisfy husband's high sex drive when
she's quote not in the mood this to me
is a great solution I love everything he
has to want a doll you'd hope he you but
they talked about it right I hope he
doesn't
she's like and she goes this is the this
is the middle this is the middle I'm
willing to put it in here now yeah yeah
put it in here I don't want to put it in
there I don't mind if I like the shower
head shower head's gone sorry hold on
you put it in here put it in love to
this I'm sick of you using our
grapefruits yeah what if it's her fetish
to watch him with it that would be
wonderful that's also fun I want to see
you it's an inanimate object that gets
me up I'm not gonna lie there's a lot of
things I'm willing to try this one of
them one of them you know what sometimes
when you have a pot you realize oh this
lid fits too right and it just this
artificial lid for anyone listening or
watching who is like what a sex doll get
out of your brain of the inflatable one
I'm not a pool raft go watch Lars and
the Real Girl and figure out that thing
thank you Jay for having the guts to say
that Dan who sent this goddamn story
again at the end about it I'm mad who
sent it in who's who's throwing this our
way
Randy walks on and all of us just kind
of who forced this sex style into our
lives but you always gotta even though
you had this mic you still yeah act like
it's a love
we'll do it live
ready yes Joe wanted to literally drive
one block away uh
a wife this is a sentence you don't
normally like a wife struggling with her
husband's high sex drive has bought him
a lifelike size a lifelike sex doll
which looks just like her for when she's
not in happy Hanukkah and okay happy
Hanukkah this is night one or eight
that's a night six you're saying about
it what'd you get last night's socks the
night before a Bed Bath and Beyond 20
gift certificate a soulless sex partner
Char gray and her what's her name Char
gray that's her name Shar probably no
that's the color of the doll's skin
honestly I was like great and her
partner column column this comes from
the daily what do you call them uh
introduced
at scholar Brothers introduce the blonde
hair doll named D wait why isn't it your
name as well why does the doll has the
most normal name
also I wonder do they tell you when they
send it to you the stall's name's D yeah
like uh it's like adopting adopting a
pet when you adopted your dog did you
change it to Charlie we did what was it
Willis oh no that is what you talking
about Charlie talk about Charlie you
changed right
no Roman was always Roman oh he was
Roman was always fitting because of
Virgil I thought that I know okay Virgil
okay Shar guy and call him introduce the
blonde hair doll named D while looking
for ways to quote spice things up in the
bedroom I would have called her Lottie
the cops are a lot the couple
who runs and only fans page oh in makeup
to how many pounds a month
how many dollars British pounds I didn't
convert it okay so they run an only fans
page what do you think they're making
Dan is this gonna upset me I can't I
don't know hold on hold on the only
thing
which means that they are have having
sex for like they're entertaining people
with like cats or he has sex with the
doll but I mean if she's like uh to keep
up with this guy's sex drive it's like
well you're if you got an only fan space
don't go join Broadway if you want to do
two shows a week that's right do you
know what the schedule is hey don't
don't there's a matinee [__] you can't
join Broadway and say I'm not gonna do
the Sunday matinee you got to do all in
seven it's eight and seven eight and
seven [__] and that's the same thing
with the sex doll eight and seven when
we started this only fans I thought it'd
be something we did once a month
turns out you got to keep up with it
sure we're making literally I'm gonna
say it per month
we're making money hand over fist which
I want to talk to you about which is how
we make it we're making money hand over
fisting uh I would say uh
uh 20 000 pounds a month what I don't
even know the conversions
eighteen thousand dollars I think
they're a little fifty thousand thousand
dollars I think they're making yeah can
I see you know what they they're
bringing in something twenty thousand
pounds would be like twenty five
thousand if she bought a lifelike sex
doll and those things run for uh not
like I know but exactly six thousand
that is unbelievable Rory because you're
buying a lifelike sex doll you could
have a little bit of coin so now if my
wife or kids pick this up in my phone
I'm gonna see how much uh just Dan do
you mind I'm gonna see how much a
regular sex doll
clear history what what no don't look
look at Live Your Life who cares tell
them I got work to do 15
000. okay what are you saying per month
Roy fifteen thousand okay I don't know I
just sold like 20 000 really I think
they probably make like 5 000 pounds a
month okay that's about seven thousand
dollars it's about six thousand five
hundred I said twenty thousand pounds I
know I went 15. follow-up dumb question
everybody forgive me I'm trying my best
the little like squiggly F that's pound
right squiggly F yes that's bounce
that's okay right I need you to confirm
because I can't even picture what you're
asking okay Randy what was your guess I
said twenty thousand twenty thousand
you're doing on your phone I'm trying to
look up how much a sex doll cost to buy
I'm sorry now I'm downloading a new
album okay I'm getting through junk
emails
3000 pounds is twenty four thousand five
twenty five thousand dollars okay so
yeah that's right yeah okay that's right
ahead of us no okay the answer is
they make up two seventy thousand pounds
a month dude I was on the right path
70 73 we're in the wrong business and
we're in the wrong business so they're
pulling in what you're saying is like 75
to 80k but I I don't think that U.S I
think that I don't think that involves D
I mean you know that's that might now
but I think they already had it on now
here's what I want to know is this what
are we is our numbers going up or down
with d yeah so now I'm gonna do Dan I'm
gonna do how many people want to see so
yeah they definitely do but it is in the
goal post oh or the bad post how much is
a how much is this you can only do Give
me the give me the an expensive sex doll
how much it looks exactly a thousand
dollars okay 3 500 bucks Jay an
expensive one forty thousand dollars
okay and now you go way too now listen I
don't know about the I don't know about
I don't know no consistency the B story
to this episode is Rory judging Jason's
guess
I'm fascinated by it yeah get mad at the
guy who shot for a sex doll for six
months tell me I don't know what I'm
talking about so the high end of a
section of at least these I'll just do
the high and now there could be forty
thousand I don't know but
the high end is thirty two hundred
dollars
Dan why do you know so much I'm in the
game almost exactly I can get one for
Less on over stuffed up they run this
only fans they had discussed exploring
group sex however Shar was unsure of the
idea and worried she might get jealous
yeah I did wonderful no you're
boundaries and express them to your
person yeah how much is a really good
sex doll
200 bucks all right good to know
how do you get your phone back out good
job
sending an email to myself you know when
you always ask me what I want for my
birthday
no I'm not doing anything vintage it's a
different kind of Club thing instead
I think you need a different chefs we
need a different shaft in here same
fitting same shafts different clothes so
they talk about getting into group sex
they decide they don't want to do it
because Char's afraid she'll get jealous
Char produced a 1.5 thousand dollar uh
pound doll so that's two
as a happy medium okay yeah that's what
you said I want to group this thing up
let's do it first of all guys spend
money it's it's expenses at the end of
the year for taxes you can write it you
can write that out you can write it you
can write the pocket vagina yeah you can
write a [__] vagina off
you notice you can write off your sex
life no not for them no sure right now
they're not off they're up yeah sharp
Sharp's like maybe shark back on camera
she now considers it quote the best
decision she ever made Stoke on Trent
live reports Char previously worked in
in end of life care talk about turning
your day around she was doing hospice
and now she's she's like she's getting
I've been with bodies that were turning
gold now you go get with that gold body
over there uh and Colin was employed as
an alloy alloy painter life care she got
her husband an inanimate object yes
exactly I'm no detective
I don't want to put two things together
but we prepare first trying out the
adults only site after introducing D to
their sex life so I guess D's always
been around he is D is the reason they
now treat d like a real person dressing
her in white lingerie and dresses taking
her out on car rides and watching their
favorite show the in-betweeners together
I know something that's in between peace
they say that that the reaction D in
betweeners there you go that's flower
Brothers they say the reaction to D can
be negative online but they don't care
what anyone thinks because it works for
them good for them who is this hurting
nobody Char said we were talking about
spicing things up and having a threesome
or foursome a little golf but like most
girls I was worried I'd struggle because
another woman it was a joint decision to
buy a sex doll but it was the best
decision and is definitely improved our
sex by the way no quotes from him he has
not given any quotes yet like what does
he think about this oh Cullum is also a
sex doll
tar is office
this will drop in so uh anybody who's
watching
um this is the best place to see all
these I'm gonna show them the photo but
you'll be able to see it while you just
keep looking at your screen you want to
see Char and D in bed together
that's a pretty close match I can't tell
you number one of them you know what's
creepy twins here let me see it let me
see it we'll pass back we'll pass a
little pass back so yeah I mean by the
way kudos to the kudos to the company
that made the doll because it looks so
much like her well and they're buying
this matching outfit and everything and
she's got that yeah they're making the
effort I mean let's not go overboard
that it looks so much it does look a lot
like it looks a lot a lot like her
similar also they're wearing the same
clothes true I could do that with Daniel
and be like you guys do look alike yeah
you start to look like your pets you
start to look like you're sexy
Dan where do you keep it when you're not
using it well they're gonna we're gonna
get into that is that utility closet you
keep it in a coffee break a vampire
do you think they got a doll that looks
just like when you open it Monster Mash
plays like when you open a greeting card
I was working in the lab
I was working in the lab real question
do you think they kind of dial it looked
just like her because she was afraid
she'd get jealous of the doll
if it didn't also represent her yeah why
did the doll need to look like her
because she was like if there's a
different type of what is like exactly
let's say it's a redhead doll that
doesn't look like her at all and he
starts having sex with the doll and he's
like okay this is what I want then he'll
go out into the world and find that as
opposed to her now just go find another
blonde no but not if this looks exactly
like her it's like you're you can only
find it's great because Colin has a high
sexual drive and if I'm not in the mood
he's got D there we both love
experimenting with her and so that means
she's experimenting with I love these
shoes let me change that of rephrase
that and when I'm not in the mood not if
right I'm not trying to be an [__]
here but honestly that looks like a 1500
doll he's saying it doesn't only have
2200 it doesn't look like uh Jason's 40
000 standards according to char quote
she's not ever researched it she's not
just a dog she's a part of the room
we're really attached to her she's
helped to strengthen our relationship
and set our sex lives on fire dude it's
a little jump start a little jump a
little maybe they're only fans is
sponsored by the company that makes this
there's a picture of all three of them
in bed you'll either be seeing it right
now or use your imagination column looks
like exam at the time of his life the
couple purchased the doll online in June
2022 after previously owning a doll that
just wasn't doing it for them cut to
that doll being like hey hey he's alive
I did my best cut to their neighbors
that's the voice
I did my best what do you want me to do
it's another okay by the way cut to
their neighbors who like come out on
garbage day and see just a pair of legs
sticking out of there you know that's
the uh the side of the Island of Misfit
Toys we never get to see
the sex doll who's there
Santa Claus shows up to save them and
she's like
and he's like
we're busy I gotta check this with Mrs
Claus I would come back I'm coming back
we got a balance balance the kid playing
kids I just put the corn
ERS
and they ended up like calling the cops
and everybody saying garbage men who
like like we got a dead body here and it
was just a second shot oh remember that
yeah
that is a forty thousand dollar sex doll
you thought that was a real dead boss
and I think Donna's gonna be okay look
how the legs are straight up I worry I
worry about Blitzen he'll talk
he's getting he runs his mouth they
opted for a more realistic model after
their first style that resembles the
blonde sharp Shar said there were so
many to choose from but we eventually
found D who we think looks like me I
don't think she's doing this on purpose
I never get jealous because there's no
emotion there she's not real but she
definitely spiced things up column has a
higher sex drive than me so it's great
that he has D when I don't want to have
sex is there any picture of column I
don't know that he exists yeah there's a
picture of Colin okay I mean it really
cuts to the core of what you need
but like you you're fine don't you love
the interaction
there's column oh man look at him look
at him he's so happy
yeah you know maybe they are having a
lot of fun we could call him he doesn't
care I wonder if he exp like breaks
stuff in like new bits on the doll he's
like nutritions yeah I'm gonna try try
this one try this with d and then I'll
bring it into what's going on with you
you know what I mean yeah there you go
well that's an interesting is that story
well okay I can't wait Daniel how old no
how old
we don't have that I just have to end it
yeah
um sent in by Carlene McDermott
Carlene we wish you well your dumb
people Town friends Daniel Van Kirk
Rory sklar and Randy scope and Jason
squeeze
Jason sweet Ulrich all right uh that's
your number two down the books I love it
a pen pal Style thank you for doing that
that way I didn't see that that was
happening I'm so dumb Jay give us a
taste just to taste what we'll see
um a 9-1-1 call maybe the most epic for
one of the most epic reasons of all time
most of the epically inappropriate
reasons oh that's on the other side of
the break and we can't wait to bring
that to you it's not people done with
Rory scope will be right now
hey guys welcome back to the show uh
boom boom boom we haven't mentioned our
patreon uh we dropped everything down to
a five dollar level you can get uh you
write the stories in and tell us what
you the dumb story that happened to you
in your life we all have them if you've
ever wanted what if ran Dan and Jay
broke down a part of my life I want that
I love it because we've all done stuff
and it's so if you guys can write it in
if you don't have a dumpster can't wait
until we do live shows and somebody's
like I'm the guy who got stuck in a
sewer yes oh you're like wait I saw that
no but that was us all the time episode
how about a hand of a round of applause
for Pennywise everybody anyways Georgie
he's nickel wise
um so no so if you write those in and
we'll do those you get those stories
Plus ad free episodes of this show so
all that stuff is great just join the
patreon we love you Jade let's take five
bucks a cup of coffee all right this is
the in the headline you get it all uh
man calls 9-1-1 after sister ends his
wash cycle
Richmond Heights Police I see exactly
I'm on his side sent in by Jake Rooney
this is about so many other things you
want 9-1-1 to do for you you you're like
I can't shoot yeah
how helpless do you feel that you feel
like the only way
you can't do it yeah I'm gonna let the
authorities take care of this this is
from a blotter so there's not a lot of
info but we can get into it officers
responded so now they have to come by
the way well I mean I guess you are on
the verge of a domestic dispute but yeah
you also don't know if that guy's
talking code right you're like we got it
and end my cycle all right officers
respond to a 9-1-1 call at a residence
September 23rd and learned that a man
had called because his sister had taken
his clothes out of the washing machine
without his permission yeah yeah consent
is half the has he never lived in an
apartment complex look no means no but I
mean we're talking about consent yeah
this is the story of stopping wet yeah
oh just just sitting on like if you
didn't do it she should be in jail
forever forever right I mean this is
like I don't believe in capital
punishment but I will for this story I
will allow it
it was his what number load of laundry
was it oh so she's had enough for this
day yeah yeah
and the woman said she took it out
because it was taking too long it always
was number one sentence for all of us to
switch
what load was it like whoa okay more
than one she's right she's right I bet
it was the fourth one seventh load for
Randy
that was the title of the story right
before this okay sex now ten thousand
left it was which number though to get
your get your answers in town is because
it was his third that's it that's still
on her side
darks and whites what's wrong with that
yes or just I mean you're at least doing
two three is not if it's towel or
betting day two four and only three
nothing but what's four I can even get
behind if you have workout clothes that
you don't want to like get washed with
all your other stuff well she's got
these places
napkins you don't want to wash with the
dog bed I get it yeah I get it here's my
question what is she mad at if it's
taking too long that's a washing machine
issue that's not a brother issue yeah
like is your washing machine anything
going or is he taking too long I think
he's putting the napkins on sanitized
you don't have to do it and you live as
you guys all remember when you didn't
you were living somewhere that has an
in-unit washer or a drive you've got to
be happy do it later
touching his laundry what are those
charges what is that one minute in jail
one minute
third degree fluff and fold like what is
the degree yeah what if he goes into
jail he will be in there on a 20 minutes
man sweater yeah instead of man's
sweater some reckless washing I don't
know Dan uh I feel like this was
technically like and I could be wrong
this is what they got Al Capone on I
might be wrong yeah he did all those
other bad things
I mean Dan you're right you went well
you asked this question initially what
could the cops do in this scenario even
if because this does happen in
laundromats or an apartment complexes
you'll come out and somebody has like
taken your clothes out of the dryer
which I think at a certain time if it's
at least been an hour and you you lose
the right I'm not saying steal them or
do anything bad to him you just take
them out you put them on the table and
it's but people will do it with wash
even if you call the cops in that
scenario just a little water charge a
person yeah Dan I'll tell you right now
he wanted to press charges but officers
advised him that no crime had been
committed that's right and then here's
where the officers I feel like are going
to town let's do it they were both told
to work out the matter as adults since
they were living together in their
grandmother's house why bring this woman
into it oh she's dead no she's dead but
it's like they is she or does or does
the pain that she inflicted live on and
the daughter was like we gotta get
Grandma in the washing machine to clean
her up
this is the adult Flowers in the Attic
this is that like and if she is nearing
death I know a woman with a sex doll who
can help her get today she can help get
her to that but this is the moment where
we are gonna we're gonna find out this
is how we we leave this one how old is
the man who called the cops nine one
will tell you everything you need to
know well he was told yeah
what are you gonna do go ahead call the
cops I will call for these I will I will
call them Rory do it these two are old
yeah that's what I was gonna say they're
old oldies and they still call it their
grandmothers well that's whose house it
is she died 40 years ago
get it inherit the house either oh no no
that's in contention
in his uh 60s so give a number 60 what
60.
I don't want you to be right but he is
24 years 24. the way you say Dan
this man who called the cops on his
sister because he couldn't handle it he
he literally she dared him to or
whatever the reason
he did it was get your answers in 27
years old oh Daniel
27 year old adult last round yeah you
got to be so young that you don't know
that that's not why you call the cops
right 27 isn't young enough like 27 is a
oh no he's [__] around age like 27 we
were on our own yeah that's what I'm
saying you're in a fuck-up age if you're
like but 27 is old enough to know if you
can rent a car you're old enough to know
so the cops if you get your chauffeur's
license you're old enough to know the
cops need to find this person a lot of
money yeah for being there the oldest
age that I would go well you're an idiot
kid is maybe 14 15. yeah I was like well
you're being an idiot you're being an
idiot imagine the cops show up you're
the sister don't aren't you approaching
the cops with so much confidence or
you're like I mean why are you guys here
yeah and they're like the same and
you're like
no like everything the cops were saying
she's right behind him going right she's
leaving the car she's leaning on the car
listen to them yeah yeah yeah yeah I
don't know why watching through the
window like
yep yep you just grumbling right but
also the confidence that he had when
they pulled up they're here they're here
now and your ass is dead you thought I
would have thought I would you think
they're here because they're not on my
side yeah they're numbered Justice
they're here because I brought them here
Grandma's gonna kick your ass out
Grandma's been dead for 35 years she's
still gonna kick her ass kick your ass
you know even the cops had the same
answers Dan Daniel they were like well
what load was it he was like the third
and they were like that could be sheets
and towels
they're now trying to figure out ways
where she's right let me feel the
laundry and see how wet it is they're
like the entire dryerable dog bed in
there you're the dummy that's never
gonna drink it probably did go both ways
we're like you're an idiot for calling
us also ma'am three loads you gotta
chill out like for both of them yeah you
too also get a different Grandma so I
don't like the defund the police label
in moniker I thought that was a horrible
misstep I do think this should be
handled by other people but that is what
it's about that's what it's about yeah
so there's another organizations
LP laundry patrol all LP what's the
number eight one one
the defending the police and just saying
that oh well there are people that could
go respond in terms of like mental
health issues that don't require a
weapon 8-1-1 this is a perfect call for
people who are in training to to get to
that level there you go hey this is a
walk in the park you're gonna have to
deal with two personalities
bring a bounce sheet and you're ready to
go you know what just take the scooter
over there yeah yeah have lunch yeah
that's a story gang there you go dumb
pen pal town we did it yeah pen pals is
their wonderful podcast that these guys
do everybody subscribe to that if you're
not all the people listen to dumb people
town you should love that you will love
it let's start out with the episode that
you guys start with ours and dig your
way back or forward it's such a
wonderful show we'll come back and do it
again we love you Rory thank you for
joining us thank you guess what great to
meet you I love that you guys met on
this podcast and you've been doing
another podcast and uh oh [__] we're
gonna get back to work
stick around make a sound there's more
than people town
[Music]